Sneakers.
The Rubber Soul innovation of the
late 1800s became pop culture
staples by the 1970s
and 80s, with models like
the Adidas Superstar, PUMA Clyde,
and Nike Air Force 1.
But it wasn't until the release of
the Air Jordan in 1985
that sneaker fandom became an
international obsession.
Here at Peep My Kickz sneaker
convention in New Brunswick, New
Jersey, resellers feed
Sneakerheads' voracious appetite
for Nike's, especially
as Air Jordan line.
This is pair of Off White Jordan 1
Highs. I'm trying to actually sell
it.
Resellers act like speculative
investors stocking up on inventory
as they bet that prices will rise,
sometimes yielding enormous
profits.
That's 220?
Appreciate you, bro. You got
Instagram?
But there is one person here who is
not selling Jordans, at least not
as Nike conceived of this shoe.
He goes by the name Naady and sells
a reimagined version of an Air
Jordan 1 under his own independent
clothing label "Global Heartbreak".
We on our third shoe.
He is part of a controversial
segment of the sneakers market.
Small label designers who
make products derivative of Air
Jordans and other Nike models.
It's all just trying to push our
artwork. Trying to push the next
man. I got a platform.
Why not use it?
Now he runs his label out of his
apartment in North Brunswick, New
Jersey.
This is my closet.
Right now this is probably the only
OGs I have.
I got him restored like twice
because they start to yellow, they
start to crack.
Black Air Force energy.
Yeah, this is only 50 made. I
probably
spent the most money on these,
and this might have been a bad
purchase. Covid happened and
school kicked us out.
We had 60%
of our dorming back and I was
like "Oh yeah, let me just
make a dumb decision".
And these were like 1800.
Naady began Global Heartbreak with
only $50 to his name,
steadily building a following
through Instagram over the past six
years.
This is supposed to be the needle
and this is the broken heart, and
the situation I was going through,
which is the heartbreak.
And then the needle would be
clothing. But then it takes two
people to mend a broken heart, and
sew it back up together.
Naady works on sneaker designs with
his childhood friend who goes by
Teeb.
My art is best when I feed off other
people's ideas and
Naady is just somebody that we just
clicked.
Remember when I had the little
carrot?
The carrot?
Yeah. Why you take that off?
Because it was ugly.
In today's decentralized makers
economy, despite running a small
independent clothing label,
Naady was able to contract directly
with a manufacturer in China to
produce his inventory.
I'd send them the file of exactly
what I want. I ask the manufacturers
to send videos of the whole process
from scratch.
You could get a good sneaker for
about $65.
We sell 100 shoes at $150.
We didn't even triple profit.
I don't like to break pockets.
I want the people from where I'm
from to be able to purchase it.
We made money back, but it was more
so about pushing our art.
Although Naady and Teeb don't
produce enough shoes for Nike to
take notice, the sneaker giant
has been cracking down on derivative
designers.
The most high profile lawsuit is
against trendsetting fashion brand
"A bathing ape" or
BAPE for short.
Bape is a really important Japanese
streetwear brand that started in the
1990s. It was embraced by
hip hop superstars Jay-Z and
Pharrell, probably the biggest among
them.
Brendan Dunne is the editor
of the leading online sneaker
magazine Sole Collector, and
co-hosts the YouTube sneaker
show Full Size Run.
BAPE was most known in sneakers for
making the BAPE STA, which is a
version of the Air Force 1 that
replaces the Nike swoosh with
a shooting star logo across the
side. If you look at the shoe and
you know anything about sneakers,
you know immediately that's based on
Air Force 1.
I wanted BAPE STA bad when I was a
teenager, and I'm happy to own a few
pairs now.
You know, you put this next to a
Nike Air Force 1 and it should be
pretty obvious the DNA of the shoes.
You don't have to be a sneaker
obsessive to see the things that
these models have in common.
This one came first.
This one came later. This
year, decades after the
original release of the BAPE STA,
Nike finally sued BAPE over
the design, calling the
BAPE STA a "knock off Air Force 1",
saying that BAPE was infringing
upon Nike's intellectual
property, the trade dress around the
Air Force 1, and asking
the court to stop BAPE
from selling these shoes.
And this action from Nike comes
amid a wave of recent litigation
where they're trying to swat down
all these makers who create these
shoes that look a lot like Nike
shoes and are very much based
on the success of Nike shoes.
It's hard to know why exactly
Nike has been so aggressive
recently. I would speculate that
there are just more of them now than
there ever were before.
And this looks to Nike like a whole
cottage industry that could get out
of control.
It seems like every six months
there's a new version of the Jordan
1 with a different logo on it.
There's some people that are just
like, "Oh, those are knock offs.
Those are for Fugazi", but then
there's some people that really look
at it as "Alright, this is
limited, a collectible".
Like especially when you go hard
with the box and then you separate
yourself with the colorway.
I feel like, from an artistic
standpoint, like everything
comes from something.
Nothing's truly original.
Like, yeah, this is something you've
seen before, but it doesn't
take anything away from being
personal to us.
We usually think that copying
actually destroys incentives to
innovate, but in the fashion world,
copying is actually what creates the
incentives to innovate.
NYU Law professor Christopher
Sprigman is the coauthor of "The
Knockoff Economy: How Imitation
Sparks Innovation".
In the book, he draws a sharp
distinction between copyright,
trademark and trade dress.
So copyright protects artistic and
literary works.
Trademark is about symbols,
words, sounds
that we use to identify the source
of products.
Trade dress has a bit of a different
flavor to it, which is sometimes
the shape of products or elements
of a product's construction tell us
where the product comes from.
Trade dress is enforced
in the fashion industry
occasionally, but what you get in a
lot of lawsuits is some pretty
dubious claims of design
being recognizable.
When these lawsuits happen,
inevitably, the Nike litigators
will come up with screenshots from
Instagram comments of people who are
confused and are thinking this is a
Nike shoe on some level.
But I believe those people are in
the extreme, extreme minority and
anybody really spending their money
on shoes like this knows that Nike
didn't produce them or Nike is not
involved.
Copying helps set trends.
Trends sell fashion.
Copying is what helps kill trends.
Copying is what helps set the trend
that comes next.
So the fashion cycle runs,
and the fashion industry's
successive waves of innovation
depend on copying.
But Sprigman sees a big difference
between derivatives, such as
BAPE's or Naady's designs and
replicas, or reps for
short, which attempt to mimic Nike's
models exactly making
them a clear case of trademark
infringement.
Replica sneakers is not something
that I personally am a fan of.
It's totally fake.
It's what we call in the street,
"fu-fu".
We don't do replicas.
Replicas are not it.
I was always taught, you can't
afford it? Don't wear it.
I would never ever wear a replica
sneaker. But when you think about
fake sneakers from the era when I
started collecting, they were more
obviously fake.
A lot of the money spent these
days on replica sneakers has to do
with recreations of shoes that
are not authorized by the companies,
but still look exactly like
and feel exactly like or as close
to exact as possible.
I think it's definitely ironic if
you consider the fact that some of
these shoes, the fake ones versus
the real ones, were made in the same
factories by the same labor force.
That is one of the harder pieces to
really square away in terms of not
wanting to everywhere fake shoes.
So if we look at the placement of
the Nike Air on the label, you can
see that the air logo at the bottom
is placed slightly higher and the
label is actually a lot smaller and
tighter on the fake compared
to the retail one.
Videos like this help buyers
distinguish between replicas and
the real thing.
But most sneakerheads aren't fooled
by replicas.
They buy them knowingly because
the differences are so subtle
and the real thing is out of reach.
So Nike and Adidas in a sense,
have learned what the luxury goods
game is about, and they're getting
into that game.
They purposely manufacture
fewer than could be sold.
They create scarcity.
The scarcity helps create a mania.
This mania helps drive up the price
on secondary markets.
It seems to me that that kind of
behavior is going to call forth
counterfeits the way rain calls for
flowers.
That's just the way the world works.
Unlike with knockoffs,
Sprigman believes that companies
have a legitimate case against
replicas, but also sees it as
a form of class bias.
People should understand what
they're getting.
But if a person buys a counterfeit
and is not fooled, I guess
the problem is that you'll be
walking out in the world with a very
high quality, counterfeit luxury
good that other people will mistake
for the real thing.
When they mistake it for the real
thing, they will impute to you the
status that in a sense, you don't
have. We have to ask ourselves,
are we really in the business of
regulating people's status?
That's a business that says that the
person without a lot of money cannot
essentially signal to the world
that they have the kind of taste or
that they have the kind of means
that a person with more money has.
This is a way of segmenting
us by economic class, using
intellectual property law as the
means. And that is a very
normatively unattractive thing for
intellectual property law to be
doing.
I do think Nike is doing fine, but
I do still think it's in their best
interest to combat counterfeits
and knockoffs, because I believe
that does divert revenue away from
them.
But I feel like Nike's battle
against bootleg makers is a game
of whack a mole more than anything
else.
BAPE is still selling its sneakers
and the company has filed for
dismissal of Nike's lawsuit.
A handful of other cases have been
dropped or settled out of court,
with derivative designers agreeing
to stop selling their products.
It's still not clear if Nike's legal
campaign will succeed in shutting
down this segment of the sneakers
market.
I see myself expanding.
I think kids now are
open to wearing different shoes
outside of just Nike Air Jordans.
There there's so many creators
because I feel like social media
plays a big part.
Fashion creativity comes from
designers looking at what other
designers are doing and playing with
those ideas.
Copying is part of the cycle that
drives the industry forward.